let's talk about energy should we while
we've been talking there about Saudi
Arabia we know that your boss has said
that he's not going to have any more oil
exploration in the North Sea the unions
are not at all happy about that are they
look I think the Trade union leaders are
entirely right to be holding us to
account on our policy I have dialogue
with them I was talking to Gary Smith
only in recent weeks about precisely the
concerns that he's raised and he's right
to stand up for his members jobs but
what I would say first of all is in
terms of the position of North Sea
Island gas
any new development that's given the
go-ahead before we come to power four
reasons of business certainty will
continue
obviously we'll continue with the
extraction that is currently taking
place but what we are saying is not only
for the drive to Net Zero but also for
value for money for the taxpayer we're
not going to then issue any new licenses
but we do have this extraordinarily
ambitious green energy program our clean
energy Sprint both to lower bills and
indeed to give us energy security
and my message is that that is about
jobs that's about the green jobs of the
future that's why we're proposing to
create GB energy to make sure that its
workers here in the UK that have those
opportunities so far from there being if
you like this this difference of opinion
we are on the same side we want to make
sure that we have those jobs here for
workers in the UK in that transition
at music to the ears of um Dale Vince
who we know is a labor supporter also
gives money to just stop oil
appropriate that labor Associates with
someone that Associates with a group
like just stop oil
I think it's up to Dale Vince who else
he wishes to give money to but Dale
Vince is somebody who is very successful
uh business uh person you know owns
forest green Rovers amongst other things
he's a perfectly uh legitimate uh donor
uh that we we should be uh taking money
from I make no apology for that
whatsoever there's a successful business
person wants to give money to the labor
party but it can hardly be said that
it's influenced our position on just
stop oil Kia Stamo has spoken about
injunctions to prevent what they're
doing Kia Stamos also said his message
should just stop oil is it's a just go
home because what they're doing is
entirely counterproductive the only
debate they seem to be promoting in the
UK is about how tough our public order
laws are and they're not building that
consensus that you need to tackle
climate change across the UK
so you are completely comfortable taking
money from a bloke who also supports the
group that disrupt uh General Public's
lives to the extent where they block
ambulances of people who are trying to
get to hospital
but I haven't come to a book with that
labor taking money from a successful
business person like Dale Vince if he
wishes to give money to other causes
that's entirely a matter for him as a
private individual our position on just
stop oil is that their tactics are wrong
and counterproductive and nothing has
stopped us being extremely robust in the
views to be given on just stop by and
the tough action that we think is
necessary to stop the disruption that
they're causing
labor wants nuclear power to be publicly
owned if each station costs apparently
on average something like 33 billion
pounds to get off the ground and where
do we get that money from
well no our position is yes that we are
going to have a state-owned uh Energy
company in terms of GB energy to drive
the renewable transition and nuclear has
to be part of that mix but we will want
to attract a great deal of private
investment as well we're doing an
extraordinary amount of business
engagement now to ensure that we are
building up that confidence in the
business Community to be able to work in
Partnership and we're very confident
about businesses working with us but
there is there's a real Point here
because when the last Labor government
left office we'd identified 10 potential
sites for nuclear power stage and of
course it's true to say it takes a
number of years to build a nuclear power
station and get it on stream supplying
energy but the conservatives have had 30
years
actually now a functioning nuclear power
station providing energy to our grid
that has to change and nuclear has to be
a central part now of our green energy
transition that the next Labor
government is determined to lead
um some of the women who have accused
Garrett Davis MP of sexual misconduct
said they feared losing their jobs if
they made a complaint
um Sky News has seen evidence that
suggests labor whips knew about the
allegations against Mr Davis months
before do you recognize that
look I I don't know about the
communication with the webs office and I
never saw any uh inappropriate behavior
myself but I think the point you've
raised in the question okay is
absolutely critical firstly about people
having the confidence to come forward
whether that's you know internally
within the labor party complaint
structure or indeed to uh Parliament but
I think it's also absolutely vital now
that having seen those extraordinarily
worrying reports in Politico that people
have now come forward and made formal
complaints and we have to treat them now
sensitively extremely seriously but
above all protect confidentiality
protect the identities of those people
and I think that's so critical going
forward because I mean I want to be part
of a parliament that has a a different
culture but where there is of course
this inappropriate behavior yeah then we
also need that robust system and part of
that system is about people with issues
coming forward having confidence in I
think that's why our treatment of this
now going forward is so important